it is april 25th 2022 and you're
watching the code report after 16 months
of hard work nuxjs version 3 has finally
hit release candidate it's been 84 years
and it was well worth the wait it's kind
of like the next js for the vue
ecosystem and at first glance the only
real difference is just one vowel but
the truth is that next has implemented
some really unique features that are
about to blow your mind if you've never
used it imagine a world where every file
has access to every component in your
project so you never have to write an
import statement ever again i never
thought i'd see it in my lifetime but
nuxjs figured out a way to handle auto
imports in a way that makes total sense
we'll look at that along with a bunch of
other features over the next few minutes
first we need to talk about its
documentation when you generate a new
project you get this extremely minimal
starting point and you're left wondering
what do i do next well just like view
itself this is a progressive framework
that can do a lot of different things
like build a single page app a static
site a server rendered site a rest api
or all these things together at once
what stands out in the documentation is
that there's a page that corresponds to
every directory in your project many of
these directories do some magic like
pages handles all of your routing like
next js and i really like how the
documentation explains what every file
and a project will do on top of that it
has traditional api documentation as
well as a ton of examples with
interactive demos now the big core
feature of nux that makes everything
else possible is a server engine they
built from the ground up called nitro it
supports ssr and static site generation
but most importantly it allows you to
deploy on the edge like on cloudflare
workers for example that means you're
not limited to node.js and you can
literally run server-side code all over
the world as close as possible to the
end user making your site extremely fast
but the one thing it doesn't do yet is
hybrid rendering where you have some
routes that are static and others that
are server rendered although this will
be supported in the future now the most
important aspect of rendering is how you
fetch data on the server if we go into a
component you'll notice we have a setup
script which contains code that will run
on the server now we can fetch data from
our api or a database with composables
like use async data or more conveniently
use fetch it makes a request then
returns a date of value that we can then
use directly in the template below and
did you notice i'm using top level
weight that makes things incredibly
simple but we're not going to stop there
one problem you might encounter with
server rendering is sending too much
data over the wire you can easily filter
the properties you need from the object
using the pick option or you can use
transform to change the format of the
data entirely but what if we want to
refresh this data later it also returns
a refresh function that we can simply
call from the client side template it
also has pending and error objects that
we can use in the ui as well so really
awesome data fetching capabilities out
of the box another thing we might want
to do while we're here is add some
dynamic data to the head of the document
one way to do it is with the head
component in the template or we can go
to our server side script and define it
in the use head composable that's useful
but one weird thing you may have noticed
here is that i'm using these components
without importing them from anywhere one
of the most mind-blowing features is
auto imports everything in the framework
is automatically available to you in any
file without an es import on top of that
any code that you define in the
composables or components directory is
made available on every page
automatically the only thing i don't
like about this is that it makes me
wonder how many hours of my life i've
wasted trying to organize my imports and
exports in other projects and one other
potential issue is name collisions but
it will give you a warning when that
occurs you might also be wondering if
this produces a massive javascript
bundle but the answer is no because it
will automatically perform code
splitting based on the components that
you use on each individual page now
let's switch gears to another awesome
feature layouts a complex application
might have multiple different types of
pages like a blog and an admin area
every page can be assigned a layout
which will wrap it with an entirely
different ui and that layout can also
have slots where specific pieces of ui
can be inserted it's just a really
practical way to compose a complex ui in
addition next also supports nested
routing very similar to the remix
framework for react and that's really
cool because it means you can transition
different parts of the ui while changing
the route without needing to re-render
the entire page and that can be really
useful for a dashboard style app yet
another challenge you'll face when
building a multi-page application is
state management like sharing data
across multiple pages nux provides a use
state composable that allows you to
define state with a shared key its value
is preserved after being rendered on the
server and then can be shared across
multiple components on the client side
another thing we need to talk about is
server routes like pages the file system
corresponds to a certain route you can
add a suffix like git post or patch to
any of these files to change the http
method that is used but what's really
awesome is that instead of sending a
response you just return a value and by
doing that it allows nux to
automatically create typings for all of
your api routes which means you get a
strongly typed api with almost no effort
there's tons of awesome stuff here and i
could keep going but let me know if you
want to see a full next tutorial in the
comments this has been the code report
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one